[Music]
are you you look so beautiful
thank you yeah it's great to have you on
the show thank you great to be here
my wife has an incredible girl crush on
you I have to tell you we watched 30
walk together and she is always like I
love her she's so beautiful yeah did she
have dreams about me yes she does the
night you are distracting me beautiful
I'm saying this in a nice way you're
very beautiful woman I can't believe you
say that you've never really dated in
your life no you you married quite young
and you never when I I went on one the
greatest date of my life my husband's my
now husband who I'm at my first day of
college I dated the same guy all through
high school and I basically and he knows
this so I'm not this is no surprise to
him cheated on him with my now husbands
oh really yeah you didn't break up with
this guy first I you know I kind of
tried to rig it just sort of rolled from
one end to the other we were 17 yeah you
know there are no morality there's no
such thing at that point
you're learning about it how do you
learn about it you know you can't that's
how you learn so tell me this first date
that you had with your now husband must
have been incredible if you decided like
on the spot to marry the guy well I
didn't decide that I just decided that I
would go on another date and then more
and more and more and and and now we're
married and it's been almost 20 years
Wow we met yeah what date and the date
involve the jazz club I mean I'm from a
small town in Massachusetts your message
yeah wouldn't message from western mass
we're like the cows are my whole family
is from Western Massachusetts with it
like Sturbridge Village you know that
whole area where I'm from even more
worse than that but yes I didn't know
people lived out there Massachusetts
Cowboys oh yeah I was told you don't
want to go out there any rate I never um
for instance I had never been in a taxi
really and my now husband my taxi driver
this magical machine on this date and
involved the jazz club and I dressed up
and wear high heels all night which I
never used to do and I'm as eighteen
years old I didn't have an ID we were
drinking alcohol and it was like so fun
and we made this amazing meal I've never
really been a fancy restaurant I used to
go to the China Buffet like that was my
shoes yeah so heat so this guy this guy
was was pulling out all the stops to
bring you over I'm just curious what was
he wearing
well when I met him on the date he
actually wore clothes but when I met him
for the very first time he was wearing a
vest with no shirt well it's real fatty
who wears a vest with no shirt it was
your homeless or something but it was
homeless chic I guess he had a
completely bare chick he's a bear chat
and then Avast over that yeah just the
vets just open kind of right show off
his you know sexy physique okay his like
he played saw he was 18 years old 19
years there was never a stage in my life
when I wore no shirt and a vest
and walked around and was like check it
out it was like a 105 degrees out that
night you know what I'm not gonna make
any excuses here 105 is best web gets
any hotter I'm going to a leather vest
what what you got to tell me what was
this what style of hair did he have an
80s cut looks actually exactly like
Jason Priestley from 90210 come on
that's right girls to a guy like you
mean you know what I mean and you're
sort of required to go you so what he
had the kind of flattop like a beautiful
you know it was more about the
cybernated have the sideburns a real
sexy time yeah ladies like that though
that's what he was sporting that look
and it's breas very bright blue eyes
he's gorgeous yeah great guy yeah I mean
I never met anyone I liked better that's
that's Chris
that's what I say to my wife every day I
still haven't found anyone I like about
her look every day you know we have not
scratched the surface I really did
please I don't say that I mean I do